[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Hogwarts headmaster Albus Dumbledore and
the unforgivable curses now those three
curses Avada Kedavra imperious and crew
see artists are known as the
unforgivable curses the use of any one
of them on a fellow human being is
enough to earn a life sentence in
Azkaban that's what you're up against
that's what I've got to teach you to
fight you need preparing you need army
but most of all you need to practice
constant never ceasing vigilance get out
your quills copy this down that was of
course Madame oudy actually Barty Crouch
jr. explaining what the unforgivable
curses are the reason for these three
curses being unforgivable is simple
legislation they were first classified
as unforgivable and illegal by the
Ministry of Magic in the year 1717 at
the same time
the strictest penalties were put in
place attached to their use before 1717
we can only assume that they were
regarded just like any other spell and
while we don't have any information to
support this there must have been some
sort of catalyst that made the ministry
truly realize how dangerous these spells
were yulik camp was the Minister of
Magic the timeless spells were outlawed
but just one year left in his turn the
three spells were truly set apart from
others and they were very clearly
categorized in Outworld
was interesting however is that while
these three spells are pretty awful and
the potential for destruction is high
there are other spells that exist in the
Wizarding World that technically have
the same capacity to do damage the
unforgivable curses are three of the
most powerful and sinister spells known
to the Wizarding World they're tools of
the dark arts and generally only used by
the darkest and most sadistic witches
and wizards unafraid of the consequences
attached to their use but something that
I've always wondered was if Dumbledore
had ever performed
one of them he lived for quite a long
time an experience but the first and
second visiting wars firsthand so surely
he had some exposure to them we know
that Albus Dumbledore has a little bit
of a dubious past having previously been
closed with Dark Wizard Gellert
Grindelwald along with Quinn Dewald he
was fully on board with the plan that
would establish a global Wizarding
hierarchy placing Wizards in power of
muggles that's right the Dumbledore that
we know and love wanted to rule over
muggles fortunately sooner rather than
later
Dumbledore's direction in life changed
for the better as he parted ways with
Grindelwald after disagreement involving
them Thor's brother at the fourth the
trio entered into a three-way duel which
resulted in the death of Alice's sister
Ariana Gillett and Albus had only known
each other for two months before parting
ways
two months of insanity as Dumbledore
would later recalled him to be
nonetheless during this time of the
pear-shaped or nervous ideas powers and
destinies of course
Dumbledore light a bit of a troubled
home life before any of that ensued as
his father had been sent to Azkaban for
attacking three Michael children after
they attacked his daughter and Alice's
sister Ariana but even after parting
ways with Grindelwald Dumbledore would
have had many opportunities to perform
unforgivable curses particularly during
the first was fleeing war and Barty
Crouch senior the head of the Department
of Magical Law Enforcement authorized
orders to use the unforgivable curses
without risk of penalty the Death Eaters
were strong and it was imperative that
the good guys start resorting to dire
measures to ensure that the reign of
darkness over the magical world could be
stopped
effectively his instructions but the
Death Eaters should be defeated by any
means necessary he adopted an attack
first and question later strategy
prioritizing killing suspects over
capturing them if appropriate Dumbledore
was the leader of the order of the
Phoenix during this time an organization
comprised of auras and other powerful
witches and wizards who shared one
common goal defeat Voldemort and the
Death Eaters the original order was
created in the 1970s and was constructed
after Voldemort returned to England from
abroad and started his campaign to take
over the Ministry of Magic and
Secutor muggle-borns the order worked
with the ministry quite closely to
defeat Voldemort and his forces and so
they were also allowed to administer
necessary force permitting the use of
the unforgivable curses the sheer power
of old Walt and his forces during the
first verses in war meant that the good
guys had to cast spells first and
question their morality second and given
that Dumbledore was the leader of the
order of the Phoenix I'm willing to bet
that he used at least one unforgivable
curse during the course of the war but
which of the three would Dumbledore have
used surely some would be more fitting
than others the Imperius curse or
imperial is most often used by dark
witches and wizards and when it is cast
on a victim they are forced to perform
the unquestioned bidding the caster
being under the control of this spell is
said to be like experiencing a wonderful
release from any sense of responsibility
making the victim extremely susceptible
to any sort of influence from the caster
this one really doesn't seem like that
models style and I'm not sure what sort
of advantage it would bring the good
guys dumb model is a huge proponent of
free will
something wished the use of the Imperius
curse were directly contradict he
believes that everyone's path is defined
by the choices and that everyone has the
capacity to change the trajectory of
their life if the will is there because
of that I think that the Imperius curse
is at least likely of the three curses
for Dumbledore to have used it just
doesn't fit with his personality it is
our choices Harry that show what we
truly are far more than our abilities
the Cruciatus curse otherwise known as
crucio is most often used by dark
witches and wizards when cast
crucio inflicts excruciating pain on the
victim pain so excruciating that is
considered to be torturous though I
don't think that Dumbledore used this
belt later in life I do think that he
may have used it as a young man maybe
even if just to learn how to use it him
and Grindelwald experimented with all
sorts of dark magic so I imagine that he
would have been curious as to how crucio
works in the order of the Phoenix there
was actually an exchange between
Voldemort and Dumbledore which seems to
possibly allude to the use of Cuchillo
you do not seek to kill me Dumbledore
called Voldemort his scarlet bias
narrowed over the top of his shield
above such brutality are you we both
know there are other ways of destroying
a man Tom Dumbledore said calmly
continuing to walk towards Voldemort as
though he had not affair in the world as
though nothing had happened to interrupt
his stroll up the hall merely taking
your life would not satisfy me I admit
there is nothing worse than death
Dumbledore it's not Voldemort you were
quite wrong said Dumbledore
however Dumbledore may have just been
referring to imprisonment as a fate
worse than death as we know that
Grindelwald was imprisoned in ermine
guard after his capture
they say he showed remorse in later
years alone in his cell at nerman guard
I hope that that is true I would like to
think he did feel the horror and shame
of what he had done the third and most
life-threatening unforgivable curse is
of course the killing curse Avada
Kedavra
Avada Kedavra purpose is simple it
causes the victim to instantly die if
you want to kill your victim then this
is the spell to use given the nature of
the first visiting war and how high the
stakes were I think that it's highly
likely that Dumbledore use the killing
curse on one or two occasions had dark
forces overcome the Ministry and the
order then there would have been no
additional line of defense to protect
the magical world by not killing orders
in the order would have been taking an
unnecessary and lethal risk capturing is
the way to deal with Death Eaters under
ideal circumstances but in times of
crisis it may just be best practice to
deal with them more permanently even if
that means sinking to their level
Dumbledore is a logical man and though
he would have avoided it wherever
possible I'm sure that he used the
killing curse when absolutely necessary
to preserve the sanctity of the magical
world there are even a few passages from
the text that support the notion the
good guys were aware of the necessity to
kill on occasion first from the
see Hallows i shall expect you and the
sovereigns in the Great Hall in 20
minutes also said Professor McGonagall
if you wish to leave with your students
we shall not stop you but if any of you
attempt to sabotage our resistance or
take up arms against us within the
castle then Horace was jewel to kill and
next from the Goblet of Fire
crouchers principles might have been
good in the beginning
I wouldn't know he rose quickly through
the ministry and he started ordering
very harsh measures against Baltimore
supporters the auras were given new
powers powers to kill rather than
capture for instance and I wasn't the
only one who's headed straight to the
Dementors without trial Crouch fought
violence with violence and authorized
the use of the unfuckable curses against
suspects and another from the deathly
hallows hurry the time for disarming is
passed these people are trying to
capture and kill you at least stun if
you aren't prepared to kill so as we can
see sometimes killing is necessary even
if you are one of the good guys
Dumbledore was a cool calculated and
practical man I have no doubt in my mind
that he would have used two varta
Kedavra on the odd occasion if it served
the greater good and that's it for this
video I hope you enjoyed it before wrap
things up I just wanted to mention that
we've launched a join button on the
channel with four different membership
types joining is just another way of
supporting their channel and it allows
us to continue putting out consistent
content for you guys every day each of
the membership types have various perks
so if you haven't had a chance to go and
check them out then do so by hitting
join and taking a look there's
absolutely no obligation to join but if
you want to support the channel further
then this is a good way of doing it